Sunday, July 11th, thousands of Cubans
and dozens of cities
around the Island Nation
took to the streets
to protest the country's
communist dictatorship
and persistent shortages in
food, energy, and medicine,
all of which have been
made worse by the pandemic.
The demonstrations have
been enabled by social media
and the internet, which only
came to Cuba in a big way
in late 2018 when
President Miguel Díaz-Canel
allowed citizens access to data
plans on their cell phones.
To better understand exactly
how Facebook, YouTube,
WhatsApp, and other social
media platforms are connecting
and empowering the Cuban people
and undermining state control,
Reason spoke with Ted Henken,
a sociologist at Baruch
College and the co-editor
of the collection, 'Cuba's
Digital Revolution'.
Ted Henken, thanks for talking to Reason
and the first question I'm gonna ask is,
how is the internet enabling
what's going on in Cuba?
Yeah, okay, I think
it's important to start
with what's not happening
and that is important
because we tend to read foreign
developments as they relate
to the internet, shallowly, and examples
of that happened a lot with Arab Spring
and calling those things
Twitter or Facebook revolutions.
And I think what's important
to understand in that sense
in general and then Cuba specifically is
that the internet is acting
as a facilitator of interests
and groups and protests and discontent
that traditionally were silenced
and didn't have any place
or channel where they could
really express themselves,
so they're not internet
revolutions, I think it's also,
it's important to call those
internet enabled uprisings
or protest movements, right?
There's an old concept called
the Dictator's Dilemma,
which is any technology
that may enter an authoritarian system
as a double-edged sword and
could help the dictator rule,
maybe legitimize the dictator
or the authoritarian leader
because of education or development, or,
you know, any kind of other
things that this technology,
in this case the internet enables,
but it's a double-edged
sword in that it can be used
for a lot of other means by other actors
and this is certainly the case in Cuba
and so that Dictator's Dilemma,
although sometimes it was read
from a perspective of technological
determination, you know,
whenever internet enters
a society, game over,
and Wael Ghonim, the
former Facebook executive
who was Egyptian, you know,
regretted his overly rosy idea
that you add internet
and the regime is over.
And he learned the hard way that yes,
the internet and social
media is useful and helpful
to undermine monopoly control
of media communications
and other aspects that are
fundamentally important
for totalitarian systems,
whether of the right or the left,
but they don't declare a winner,
they change the game in important ways.
Can you take a step back and explain why,
how did the internet come to Cuba?
You've written about how in
December, 2018, you know,
basically data plans were allowed
for phone service or 3G Mobile.
Why did that happen?
Well, that's a head-scratcher because,
and it goes back to the
Dictator's Dilemma, I mean,
before that you basically
have a period in the 90s
when Cuba was actually pretty advanced
in the region, in Latin
America and the Caribbean
in terms of its networking and internet
and that kind of thing, but Fidel
and the leaders at that time
realized that this could be a,
they called it a wild colt
that needed to be tamed, right?
And they saw it as a mortal threat
because it undermined
monopoly information control
which is one of the fundamental hallmarks
of the Cuban system.
The mass media is propaganda and Cuba,
there's no two ways about
it and almost everyone right
or left who understands and
studies Cuba would grant that
and so the internet in
that sense, you know,
has a revolutionary,
or you could say a counter
revolutionary potential,
but because of under development,
because of priorities,
and because of that fear,
and you could even add
because of the U.S. embargo
isolating and cutting Cuba off
from these kinds of communication
influences, technologies,
because it was part of
the overall embargo,
Cuba isolated itself and was isolated.
That gradually ended when
Raul Castro became president
in 2008 and gradually thereafter
Cubans started getting,
gradually, but very gradually online,
they started getting cell phones,
they started to be able
to buy and use laptops.